ma tutti qualcuno dire che mi aggiungo
come giorno dopo giorno i videogiochi
stanno lentamente prendendo il
sopravvento su tutti noi vuol dire io
sono uno di quei tipi di ragazzo che non
gioca mai ok cento senza non mi chiedo
mai davanti alla playstation o a queste
cose che noi diciamo che ti base io sono
un portatore sano di handicap da console
nel senso mi spiego io non ho bisogno di
base a giocare alla playstation o quello
che all'interno company xbox però quando
mi siedo è la fine del mondo cioè mitch
siena non ci sta 15 caso magari queste
sono puri bravo a quella cosa
niente proprio alla fine per poi io sono
uno di quei tipiche che chi è abituato a
vecchi a vecchi giochi quelli dovrete
usare l'immaginazione quel tipo di cose
allora io sono qua dato verde e il 40 se
invece il dragone sputa fuoco
e in quella cosa che li già attaccata al
caso verde alle spalle o dietro a
nascondervi dietro lo si sa conferire
l'agguato
qui si va avanti a destra ed a sinistra
niente agguati con queste nuove cose che
sono praticamente super futuristi vere
scomparti caso la gocciolina di sudore
che scende lungo il collo di di lara
croft mente salta no recentemente sono
andato a casa di un mio amico al quale
hanno pregato la cui come del resto
hanno fatto a me questo questo natale e
dice che ancora ho giocato perché avendo
tre fratelli non è e non mi sembrano un
appassionato del gioco non ho mai avuto
occasione di mettermi c è quindi sono
andato da questo l'unico e stato
divertente è ok e sei venuto ma ora la
tuta e non serve mica io questo secondo
viaggio cartello è sì ma con il mio
novissimo nintendo wii terni questo
quarta doppietta
io sono prova delicati il centrino si
sono appoggiati miglior on the
sì sì tv visiere no quindi sì prima
magone animati maggio attivo come adesso
che avete come si fa
capito cioè entri in un loop nel quale
vinci vinci vinci vinci poi se arriva
qualcuno che osa batterti è la fine del
mondo dietro
cioè io conosco persone che sono state
notti notte ad allenarsi pur di riavere
i loro personaggi più forti di tuoi
insomma per concludere stiamo venendone
succhiate i nostri neuroni stanno tutti
quanti venendo preside decidi tu dai a
fidarmi